en este vídeo vamos a trabajar con un
interesante problema de distribución si
en el problema nos dice que nosotros
queremos comprar un restaurante y que
hablamos con el dueño acerca de cuánta
gente va al establecimiento y nos
entregan la siguiente tabla en el que
tenemos los distintos días de la semana
lunes martes miércoles jueves viernes y
sábado se ve que el domingo descansa y
abajo en una segunda fila el valor
esperado en porcentaje es decir del
total de los comensales que van que
acuden a este establecimiento en una
semana un porcentaje de cómo se
distribuyen según los días así tenemos
que el lunes va un 10% el martes también
un 10% el miércoles nos dijo que va a un
15% 20% los jueves el viernes va un 30%
y el sábado el 15% restante
pero esto a nosotros no nos satisface
entonces lo que hacemos es ir al
establecimiento y observar cuántas
personas realmente van a ese restaurante
a comer entonces vamos el lunes y el
lunes vemos 30 personas vamos al martes
y vemos 14 personas el miércoles vemos
34 el jueves 45 el viernes 57 y el
sábado vemos 20 personas por lo tanto
tenemos la tabla en esta tabla tenemos
el valor que nos dijo el dueño del
restaurant al que nosotros queremos
comprarle y que se distribuyen de la
forma que está acá en los porcentajes
ahora cuando nosotros vamos a hacer la
observación vemos otra otra distribución
o una distribución una muestra que nos
entrega una distribución distinta
entonces lo que nosotros queremos
averiguar es a través de un test de
hipótesis si el dueño o si los datos
entregados por el actual dueño del
restaurante son correctos
o si son falsos para eso vamos a tomar
una hipótesis nula que nos diga que la
distribución
del dueño
correcto
de esta forma nosotros estaríamos
intentando rechazar esta hipótesis para
asumir o para o mejor dicho queremos
rechazar esta hipótesis en favor de
nuestra hipótesis alternativa que dice
que la distribución del dueño no es
correcta
entonces la distribución
del dueño
es correcta
para esto vamos a trabajar con un nivel
de significación alfa de 0 0 5 es decir
del 5% acto seguido lo que vamos a hacer
es asumir
asumimos la hipótesis nula al asumir la
hipótesis nula bueno vamos a tener que
trabajar con los datos que nos da el
dueño del local pero para eso vamos a
trabajar un poco más con esta tabla
fíjense que la cantidad de personas que
fueron a este restaurante en la semana
son 30 más 14 + 34 30 14 44 más 34 38 68
más 20 68 más 22 un 88 más 45 más cuevas
57 son 200 personas en total 200
personas asistieron al restaurante en
una semana entonces en una tercera fila
nosotros vamos a notar la observación
la observación esperada
la observación es esperada
para para el dueño o la observación
esperada es decir según los porcentajes
que nos entregaron como tendría que ser
realmente la observación que nosotros
tuvimos por lo tanto para eso vamos a
tener que averiguar cuánto sería el 10
por ciento de 20 es decir el 10 por
ciento de 20 de 20 9 200 perdón el 10%
de 200 para el martes el 15 por ciento
de 200 para el miércoles el 20 por
ciento de 200 para el jueves el 30 por
ciento de 200 para el viernes y el 15%
de 200 para el sábado entonces vamos a
tener
que el 10% de 200 es 20 al igual que
para el martes tenemos otra 20 el 15% de
el 20 por ciento de 240 tenemos 60
comensales que tendrían que ir el
viernes y otros 30 comensales que
tendrían que ir el sábado es decir que
si nosotros respetamos o si el el dueño
de este restaurante estuviera en lo
correcto al decirnos que esta es la
distribución de los comensales que
asisten al restaurant durante una semana
la observación que nosotros tendríamos
que haber hecho es la siguiente 20 20 30
40 60 y 30 y así se estaría el dueño en
lo correcto veamos entonces
si con estos datos nosotros queremos
averiguar voy a borrar esto
si con estos datos de la observación
esperada nosotros quisiéramos averiguar
una estadística si cuadrado vamos a
escribirlo
estadística
tica
y cuadrado
que esto es igual a la variable
aleatoria x al cuadrado
tendríamos que hacer la diferencia la
diferencia entre los valores que
observamos en cada día y lo que
tendríamos que haber observado es decir
tendremos que hacer para el lunes por
ejemplo 30 menos 20 al cuadrado la
diferencia entre lo que observamos
realmente y lo que tendríamos que haber
observado por lo tanto vamos a hacer es
nuevos 30 menos 20 al cuadrado y esto lo
vamos a expresar en función de lo que
tendríamos que haber esperado es decir
lo vamos a dividir por el mismo valor de
20 a esto le vamos a sumar 14 menos 20
al cuadrado
sobre 20
+ 34
- 30
al cuadrado sobre 30 más
45 menos 40 al cuadrado
sobre 40
entonces tenemos lunes martes miércoles
jueves más sigo acá abajo más
57 -
60 al cuadrado sobre 60 y por último a
esto le sumamos 20 menos 30 al cuadrado
sobre 30 respectivo al día sábado
ahora realizamos todas estas operaciones
ahora que había quedado de antes y nos
queda lo siguiente el primer término es
30 menos 2010 y es al cuadrado 100 100
sobre 20 más
14 - 20 es menos 66 al cuadrado es 36 36
nos quedan 16 sobre 30 más 25 sobre 40
más 57 menos 60 es 33 al menos 3 perdón
menos 3 al cuadrado es 99 sobre 60 y por
último tenemos otra vez 100 sobre 30 en
este caso y al sumar todas estas
fracciones obtenemos el valor
11,44 es decir que este valor
es nuestro
nuestro valor crítico este nosotros
tenemos que averiguar la probabilidad de
obtener este valor crítico dentro de una
tabla de valores y entonces para
averiguar qué tan que por cuál es el
porcentaje de este valor crítico
tendríamos que remitirnos a esa tabla
que les mencionó pero si antes de ir a
eso si este valor tiene una probabilidad
menor es decir si la probabilidad
conseguir 11,44 habiendo asumido la
hipótesis nula es menor al 5% en este
caso rechazaríamos
rechazamos
la hipótesis nula pero para eso vamos a
tener que ver qué probabilidad o cuál es
la probabilidad de conseguir un
resultado tan extremo como éste
en la tabla de valores pero para eso
antes de recurrir a este valor porque
hay veces que hay valores que no
aparecen en la tabla nosotros cómo
sabemos que tenemos
un nivel de el 5 por ciento ó de 0 05
podríamos buscar
cuál es el valor el valor crítico cuál
es el valor crítico para este 0 0 5
entonces vamos vamos a buscar este y
después recibo explicando antes que nada
cuantos cuál es el nuestro cabo cuál es
nuestro caso cuántos grados de libertad
tenemos
grados de libertad
bueno esto es sencillo averiguar los
grados de libertad ya que tenemos seis
días o seis columnas seis conjuntos de
valores y para eso tenemos que hacer n
menos uno en el menos uno sería 6 menos
uno entonces acá es igual a 5 tenemos 5
grados de libertad
ahora bien vamos a buscar el valor 0 0 5
para 5 grados de libertad
vamos a buscar en la tabla acá tenemos
las curvas de distribución fíjense la
curva correspondiente a nuestro trabajo
sería de esta la que está marcada en
en este color púrpura que lo estoy
remarcando en naranja pero vamos a
buscar entonces lo que vinimos a ver
005 estamos ubicados por acá
y tenemos que buscar para 5 grados de
libertad es decir estamos en 11,07
11 07 11 07 es menor que nuestro valor
crítico es decir vamos vamos a notar eso
acá abajo
11.07
es menor que 11 44 eso es seguro
entonces
la probabilidad de conseguir 1144 va a
ser mayor va a ser menor perdón va a ser
menor que la probabilidad de conseguir
un 11 07 esto es sencillo porque 11,44
es mucho más crítico que 11,07
supongamos que tenemos una distribución
siguiente nosotros estamos acá
esto llega hasta el 6 pero supongamos
que sigue sigue así hasta el 11 acá va a
estar el 12 y acá está nuestro eje
no se le deje que continúe 11,40 11,11
07 está por acá es decir que acá
11.07 con una probabilidad del 5 por
ciento y 11 como 44 está por acá
por lo tanto 1144 es mucho más crítico
es decir tiene una probabilidad mucho
menor de ocurrir
como la probabilidad es menor
quiere decir que la probabilidad de
11,44 es menor al 5%
y de esto podemos decir finalmente que
rechazamos
la hipótesis nula